It's beautiful. I can see the ocean. It's been
quite a while since I transferred, but there's still so much I do
n't know.
There are five different sports day teams, and I
feel like a hero of justice.
Yes, I'm sure there will be many new discoveries to come.
But, Nishimura  I want to make that come true with Nishimura-san.
[Music]
I want to do my best not by myself, but with Nishimura-san. Hey,
what are you doing? Let's both go home quickly. You're so
young, Akane-chan.
What is youth?
[Music]
Not in place of you, but
with Takada-kun, Takada-kun and me too, Nishimura-san, Takara-kun
Takada,
didn't you make some really loud noises just now?
[Applause] I'm
begging you if you're okay
[Applause]
[Music]
Not in your place, but with
me.
Akane Nishimura.
Nice to meet you. I'm the mother of the sun. Nice to meet you. I
'm Akane's father. I'm sorry for the inconvenience this trip has caused.
Pocky, Takada-kun's arm has been broken.  But don't worry, I'm receiving treatment now.